what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and lately there has been a lot of news
going around about the casting of the
Fantastic Four and yes everybody is
super excited and very eager to know who
is going to be Marvel's first family in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe yes there
are a lot of talks about a lot of
different actors who could possibly be
playing the roles of Reed Richards Sue
storm Johnny Storm and Ben Grimm however
we have recently heard some news about
the casting for the villain of the
Fantastic Four movie and based off of
everything that we know so far about who
the villain is going to be or at least
one of them and the main one is going to
be we've heard and the report suggest
that the villain is indeed going to be
Galactus and before any thoughts Cross
Your Head whatsoever no Galactus is not
going to be a giant cloud and yes
Galactus is going to speak in the new
Fantastic Four movie and hopefully
Galactus isn't just going to be a one
and done villain hopefully he's going to
be more like Loki or Thanos I don't
believe that he is going to be a big bad
but I do think he's going to appear in
more than one project it would be such a
shame if Galactus only showed up for one
Fantastic Four movie and would be a huge
waste but I don't think Marvel is going
to do that fingers crossed at least but
we have been hearing news about who
could possibly be voicing Galactus in
the MCU and based off of what we know
the actor who is going to be playing
Galactus isn't just going to be voicing
him but actually physically playing the
role of Galactus so whoever they get to
play Galactus their face will be inside
that awesome helmet and it seems like
right now as Marvel Studios is
finalizing the casting of the four
Fantastic Four members they are also
finalizing the casting for the villain
Galactus and so far we have heard some
huge names that are in the running to
play the role but we recently found out
from a report from Grace Randolph that
Marvel Studios met with Denzel
Washington to talk to him about playing
the world Devourer now obviously this is
a huge name and we're about to talk
about some other huge names that could
be Galactus as well but Denzel
Washington that's a really big name and
I can picture the voice now however
according to Grace Randolph Denzel
Washington declined the offer to play
Galactus which is kind of a bummer
because I do think that Denzel
Washington's voice would have made for a
great Galactus voice and also I think
him suited up as Galactus would have
been really cool as well however there
are still many other roles that he could
play in the Marvel Cinematic Universe I
am excited for two names that have been
thrown around though who could possibly
be playing Galactus and one of them who
you might have heard recently is Antonio
Banderas I personally am a really big
fan of Antonio Banderas and I do think
that his voice would suit Galactus well
and he is an actor who just has
incredible range he's been acting for a
very long time and I think if given the
chance he could could crush this roll
now this report is coming from The
Insider my time to shine hello and The
Insider does have a good track record
however it is important to know that
they do not say that Antonio Banderas
has been cast but is in negotiations
currently with Marvel Studios to play
the role another Insider Alex P from the
cosmic circus also kind of backs up this
report as well and another name that has
been thrown out there and this one is
just kind of a rumor for now is Liam
Neeson and I think that this is a voice
that a lot of people have thought could
be just very very awesome for Galactus
and I think more than any other one out
there his face might be best suited for
Galactus although I definitely think
that Antonio Banderas could also rock
that Galactus helmet it is interesting
hearing about casting because primarily
the actor who is going to be playing
Galactus it is just going to be their
face the rest of the body has a full
suit on it's probably going to be mocap
CGI so it is primarily going to be all
about their face and regarding the
Fantastic Four movie the casting in
general not just the main Fantastic Four
members casting but the villain and
villains of the movie and other
characters that'll show up as well we've
heard Kevin feige is extremely involved
in the casting process this is one
project that Kevin feige is a little bit
more involved with than the others so
hopefully that means everything is just
going to be spot on when it comes to
Casting and the story but as of right
now it looks like Antonio Banderas is
the front runner to play Galactus and is
in current negotiations so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
we'll do an update video if we hear
anything at all we also have some news
about Spider-Man across the spider-verse
today it looks like it is breaking
records already this time for the
official run time and it's going to be
the third longest Spider-Man film out of
all of the live-action Spider-Man films
that we've gotten before and of course
into the spider-verse as well according
to The Insider cryptic 4K qual who has
been very reliable when it comes to
scooping run times across the
spider-verse is going to clock in at 2
hours and 20 minutes making it the
longest ever major Hollywood studio
animated movie which is awesome I really
enjoyed the first one a lot of fans
really did as well so I'm excited to get
more in the second movie and like I said
this also clocks in at third for longest
Spider-Man movie ever Spider-Man no way
home is currently first at 2 hours and
28 minutes and then The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 is second with 2 hours and
22 minutes only beating it by two
minutes the first into the spider-verse
film clocked in at 1 hour and 56 minutes
so the sequel will be 24 minutes longer
and this sequel is going to have as
we've all seen from the trailers even
more Spider-Man variants and now we are
officially less than a month away from
its Premiere it hits theaters Friday
June 2nd and now we're going to talk
about something that has been kind of
controversial between fans and fandoms
James Gunn who of course directed The
Guardians of the Galaxy movies and is
now the head over at DC Studios running
it with Peter Safran has confirmed that
there have been active talks about a
Marvel DC crossover and in an interview
with deadline gave us kind of a timeline
for it and the feelings of a lot of fans
are kind of up in the air right now I
think a lot of people would love to see
characters like Batman on screen with
characters like Thor we'd love to see
characters like the Scarlet Witch
interact with Wonder Woman or the Green
Lantern it really is a very cool thing
to think about however of course it does
have the possibility of going extremely
wrong which is why James Gunn says that
some things definitely need to happen
first before we get a crossover he
recently said I think there's always the
possibility of that speaking about the
crossover I think that would be a fun
thing for fans to see but I do think
it's just about grounding the Marvel and
DC universes right now and trying to
make them each as strong as possible and
that is entirely what needs to happen
before this crossover could happen
especially when it comes to DC and this
this is kind of where James Gunn gives
us a possible timeline of when we could
see this happen because James Gunn
essentially has an entirely new universe
to plan out and get going we don't even
have the first movie from the new DC
Universe yet so there's a whole universe
to establish and a lot of characters to
establish in that universe so in an
interview with deadline at the Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 premiere they asked
him about that crossover and James Gunn
said I think that it would look like
something that would be happening in
about 10 years not today because we have
a whole bunch of other DC movies we need
to tell but yeah I think it could be
cool now James Gunn stated that he
pitched this years and years ago a
Marvel DC crossover back when he wasn't
associated with DC really that much at
all but now that he is the head over DC
Studios and he has an incredibly tight
connection with Marvel Studios and
specifically Marvel Studios as president
Kevin feige he has now brought this up
again as a very very real and big
possibility and I do think that it would
go well if what James Gunn said has to
happen happens the Multiverse needs to
be a little bit more established in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and a little
bit more controlled right now the
Multiverse isn't really controlled by
any of the main heroes yes Doctor
Strange has kind of traveled the
Multiverse but he needed America Chavez
to do it and he also didn't really have
any control over it and neither did she
in fact he kind of broke the Multiverse
in Spider-Man no way home so yes a lot
of things need to happen in the MCU and
a lot of years need to go by in the MCU
to establish this Multiverse and kind of
get a hold of it a grip of it to where
Heroes can actually use it to travel to
other multiverses if they need to which
we know is going to happen after the
King Dynasty and during Secret Wars it's
going to be a huge Multiverse battle
where a lot of different variants from a
lot of different universes team up
together to fight Kang and his variants
and like I said unlike James Gunn said
there's a lot that needs to happen at DC
Studios is right now we have no idea who
Superman is who Batman is going to be
Wonder Woman the Green Lantern we have
no idea if Jason Momoa is staying as
Aquaman or if Ezra Miller is staying as
the flash basically the whole universe
over at DC needs to be established but
it looks like they're going into this
new universe establishing that the
Multiverse does indeed exist so both
universes Marvel and DC are kind of
preparing for this to be a very big
possibility the groundwork has either
been laid in the MCU or is about to be
laid in the DC Universe with The Flash
movie so I personally think that Kevin
feige and James Gunn teaming up to do
that I think that would work I think the
two of them know exactly what it would
take to make that a big success and I'm
really excited to see that and I hope it
happens but let us know all of your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and leave a comment so you can
enter our giveaway for a chance to win a
PS5 and Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to choose and we pick a
winner at the end of each month you can
also follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof